all right so as you guys may or may not
know when I'm making a video there's
always something that's just one thing a
story a joke whatever that I have to
leave in the cutting room floor because
you know the videos going on like over
three minutes long and whatnot and it's
kind of dragging on take my bad teacher
review for example there was a true
story I had in there from elementary
school and I ended up leaving it out
because the video was going on over
three minutes I didn't want to drag it
on or anything like that but I really
like the story so I want to show it to
you guys so here is actually a deleted
scene from my bad teacher review and to
enjoy you have to know only one thing
and that is that this is real in fourth
grade this [ __ ] actually happened so
here you go so I want you to see a
really cool representation of the behind
the curtains of a teacher's life because
when I was in fourth grade I had one of
those squiggle pens and squiggled and it
made squiggly lines and it did that by
vibrating really really fast the thing
would be like so my teacher was like hey
when you go to recess can I see that I
just wanted I want to show one of the
other teachers that I just think it's
funny news I want to you know show them
and give me your pen when you go to
recess please it's always like okay my
teacher she was actually pretty cute too
yours like two years ago I was like I
got my squiggle pen I wonder what ever
happen to this schoolgirl pen it was
funny it was just wiggle and actually
kind of reminded me of a vibrator and
the teacher I asked to see it when I
went to recess and oh holy [ __ ] ever
since then I've been curious what goes
on behind closed doors
since the teacher masturbated with my
squiggle pen yeah actually happened
which is quite awesome other thing about
it for some odd reason I was laying in
bed I was ready to fall asleep and I was
like no they have to know this story now
you all can go about your lives with the
possibility of being complete human
beings yeah now there's a party let my
teacher do this go go Penn smells funny
[Music]